I've been telling people online in
various ways and in lectures that they
should start fixing up the world by
cleaning up their room and I wanted to
just elaborate on that a little bit
before I get back to the lecture itself
so as it's become this internet weird
internet meme you know and and and and
it's a joke and good it's a joke I'm
really happy about the fact that so much
of this has got like the leaving of
humor and it's really important because
that's what stops things from
degenerating into into conflict humor
and I was thinking about this idea of
cleaning up your room in relationship to
the mustard seed idea and you see the
thing about cleaning up your room this
is also something I learned from Carl
Jung and his study is on alchemy because
for Jung when the alchemist was
attempting to make the philosopher's
stone he was not only engaged in the
transformation of the material world but
he was engaged in the process of self
transformation that occurred at the same
time as that the chemical Trent as the
chemical transformation so the
psychological work in some sense let's
say you want to sort out your room and
beautify it because the beauty is also
important and let's say that all you
have is just a little room like you're
not rich you're poor and you don't have
any power that's another thing but
you've got your damn room and you've got
this space right in front of you you
know that that's a part of the cosmos
that you can come to grips with and you
might think well what's there in front
of you right in front of you and the
answer to that is it depends on how open
your eyes are that's the proper answer
because you could say and William Blake
said this for example Aldous Huxley make
comments that we're very similar that in
a transcendent state you can see
infinity in the finite and you might say
well you can say and you can see
infinity and what you have within your
grasp if you look and you could say
maybe that's the case with your room and
so you want to clean up your room well
okay how do you do that exactly well a
room is a room is a place to sleep
and so if you say your room ups properly
then you figure out how to sleep and
when you should sleep and how you should
sleep and then you figure out when you
should wake up and then you figure out
well what clothes you should wear
because they have to be arranged
properly in your dress and then you have
to have some place to put your clothes
you're going to have some clothes you
have to figure out what you're going to
wear those clothes to do
right and then that means you have to
figure out what you're going to do and
then your room has to serve that purpose
because otherwise it doesn't set up
properly and if it doesn't set up if it
doesn't serve your purposes you will be
unhappy and not happy in the room
because the way that we perceive the
world is as a place to move from point A
to point B in and then if the place that
we're in facilitates that movement then
we're happy to be there and it's a place
that we're in serves as an obstacle to
that movement then we're unhappy to be
there and so what it means to set up
your room is that you have to have
somewhere to go that's worthwhile or you
can't set up your room and then your
room has to be set up to facilitate that
and then the next thing is well maybe
you have to make it beautiful but that's
not easy right that means you have to
have some taste and that doesn't mean
you have to have money it doesn't
because you can be garish with money and
you can be tasteful with nothing all you
need is taste and taste beats money when
it comes to beautifying things you know
I mean not that money is trivial because
it's not but taste is crucial and people
who are very artistically oriented to
make beautiful things out of virtually
nothing and not only that the literature
suggests that if you're going to make
beautiful things putting real
constraints on on what you allow
yourself to do facilitates creativity
instead of interfering with it because
let's say you have to make something out
of nothing right which I suppose would
be a godly act right you have to make
something out of nothing it you have to
be creative in order to do that and so
then to beautify your room means that
you also have to develop your capacity
to be creative and so then you can make
your room shines but then what will
happen is that if your family isn't
together they will interfere with that
you'll interfere with that because you
won't have the discipline to do it
properly but then when you start
building this this this little microcosm
of perfection with what you have at hand
then Italy evoke all the pathologies of
everyone in your household they'll
wonder what the hell you're up to in
there and they won't necessarily be
happy because if you're if they're in a
lowly place let's say and so are you and
you're trying to move out of that then
the higher you move out of that the more
the place they're in looks bad and you
might say well what they should do is
celebrate your victory
over chaos and evil but that isn't what
will happen what will happen instead is
that they will attempt to pull you back
down they'll attempt to and I mean
obviously all families still do that but
but all families do that to some degree
and some families do almost nothing but
that and so what that means is that if
you're going to organize your room then
you're going to have to confront the
devil's in your house and that's often
that's often a terrifying thing because
some of those Devils have have lineages
that go back many many many generations
and god only knows what you have to
struggle with in order to overcome that
and so and then and so to sort yourself
out and to fix up your room is a non
trivial matter you know and you can do
that you'll learn by doing that and then
maybe you'll learn enough by doing that
so that you can fix up your family a
little bit and then having done that
you'll have enough character so that
when you try to operate in the world at
your job or maybe in the broader social
spheres that you'll be a force for good
instead of harm because you'll have
learned some humility by noting just how
difficult it was to put your damn room
together well and yourself for that
matter and so you'll proceed cautiously
with your eyes open towards the good